استطلاع أجرته يوجوف في وقت
اليوبيل البلاتيني هذا الأخير فقط قد
وجد أن 62 في المائة من البريطانيين قالوا إن
بلادهم يجب أن تستمر في الحكم
الملكي في المستقبل مع 22 في
المائة فقط قالوا إنه يجب أن ينتقل بدلاً من ذلك إلى
وجود رئيس دولة منتخب ولكن
هناك فجوة جيلية صارخة
تُسأل عما إذا كانت الملكية جيدة للبريطانيين
74 من أولئك الذين يبلغون من العمر 65 عامًا فأكثر ، أجيبوا بنعم
بنسبة 67 بالمائة من أولئك الذين تتراوح أعمارهم بين 50 و 64
عامًا.
24 في المائة
من الصفحة الأولى اليوم من نيويورك تايمز
تحتوي على هذا العنوان الرئيسي في لندن
الحداد على الملكة تكشف عن
فجوة دعم الأجيال للملكية
تتلاشى بين الشباب ،
وهناك فرصة لأن اليزابيث بعد إليزابيث قد ينقسم
المودة للنظام بأكمله إلى
بعض من هذا قد يكون مجرد شباب.
العداء الذي يمكن أن يضعف بمرور الوقت ،
لا تنظر إلى أبعد من رئيسة وزراء إنجلترا الجديدة
نفسها في عام 1994 ،
ألقت ليز ترست خطابًا ناريًا يدعو إلى
إنهاء النظام الملكي.
يجب أن يولد الناس ليحكموا
أو أنه يجب عليهم أن يصمتوا ويصمتوا
بشأن القرارات التي تؤثر على
حياتهم اليومية ، التقينا بمجموعة أخرى من
الناس ومجموعة أخرى من الناس
وجميع المجموعات الثلاث من الناس قالوا
إلغاء الملكية
في الواقع مؤتمر لم نتمكن من  لم أجد
ملكًا واحدًا
خارج الجناح الملكي كيف أنه من السخرية
الآن بالطبع في منصبها الجديد المتمثل في
الثقة في السلطة أنهت خطاب العزاء
العلني للملكة يوم الخميس مع
حفظ الله للملك
عبارة لم تنطق في
إنجلترا منذ سبعة عقود